wir schauen direkt zum nato gipfel der
gerade in madrid läuft ein highlight für
die meisten staatschefs dort scheint ein
treffen mit den klitschko-brüdern zu
sein jeder wirklich jeder wollte einfach
ein foto mit den ehemaligen weltklasse
boxer machen sei es nato-generalsekretär
ian stoltenberg olaf scholz ursula von
der leyen sehen wir hier oder auch
österreichs bundeskanzler keine hammer
und auch kanadas premier cru du ja die
nachricht sie die klitschkos zahlt den
staatenlenkern mit auf den weg geben die
bitte um mehr um schnellere
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine und wir
freuen uns ganz besonders jetzt sprechen
wir nämlich mit vladimir klitschko uns
live zugeschaltet aus madrid schön dass
sie bei uns sind oder glauben sie mir
den scherz zum anfang sie sind der echte
wie oft kriegen sie diese frage jetzt
gestellt
es kommt darauf an welche rechte also
ich bin nicht der bürgermeister ganz oft
wenig verwächst wurden gemeistert da
muss ich immer wieder betonen das bin
ich nicht so weit dass bei joe biden
dachte dass ich wieder libyen das war
aber umgekehrt kann das foto auch
gesehen mit ihnen und joe biden das
jetzt um die welt geht was haben sie mit
dem us amerikanischen präsidenten
besprochen was kann man überhaupt in so
einem moment dann auch besprechen oder
zieht man sich dann für die wichtigen
gespräche noch mal zurück außerhalb auch
der presse
also ich war definitiv produktive
gespräche von joe biden zu ausgaben um
selbst brot gesagt hat dass hier
unterstützen die für ihre da sein kann
wie gemacht und von der seite unserer
gestalten oder nato als allianz
sie fordern mehr waffen es braucht auch
mehr munition und es muss schnell gehen
ja wie war das thema jetzt beim
nato-gipfel welches feedback haben sie
bekommen
es war wirklich ein historisches
nato-konferenz weil das hauptthema bei
allen gesprächen dort wo wir immer
liiert waren und nicht nur ukraine dies
ist ihre musik wie ihr seid zweiten
weltkrieg in europa in einer großen
europäischen lernt und wie die ukraine
ist stattfindet um diese aggression von
russische seite die kommunisten seit
februar und auch geblieben ist ist
deshalb man seine spuren hinterlassen
beim menschen die welt der freien welt
sozusagen entschuldigen diese
unterstützung und anerkennung
analysen gibt will russland 1 aggressor
als ein staat der der
das
töten
um die ukraine und auch gefahren für
weitere länder darstellt es ist
unglaublich wichtige mäßig gewesen von
hatte das zu erkennen das muster und
agiert während
aber was gibt es jetzt für direkte
konsequenzen was passiert ab jetzt es
gab g7 hier bei uns in deutschland jetzt
also der große nato gipfel in madrid was
werden wir auch zu spüren bekommen was
bekommen auch die ukraine in ihrem land
jetzt zu spüren direkt
also es geht natürlich in einem krieg zu
verteidigen und es geht um die
waffenlieferung gebiet um die
unterstützung natürlich auch eine
möglichkeit für die krise an nato sich
zu beteiligen oder teil der nato zu sein
weil letztlich wir brauchen eine
kräftige brauchen eine unterstützung wie
broken städten oder eine remission sowie
die nato ist das uns zum beschluss unter
wieder als teil von adressieren also das
ist noch offen also dass die touris
führungs nach offen und westens ganz
wichtig gewesen dass noch einmal nach
diesem gipfel zu bekommen und
letztendlich es dauert alles viel zu
lang und es muss schneller als auch
funktionieren und agiert werden jeder
schaut die situation jeden tag jede jede
sekunde zählt weil während des gesprächs
jetzt laufen die grenzen im osten und
süden der ukraine und deswegen es ist
enorm wichtig gewesen und dass die
nato-staaten und dass die freie welt uns
unterstützten mit waffen mit humanitäre
hilfe und natürlich auch die garantie
dass so was nicht nach dem ende des
krieges und ich hoffe dass das ende
sobald wir es geht nur kommt dass nach
ende des krieges auch eine garantie für
unsere stadt darstellt wie blicken sie
derzeit auf deutschlands auf der einen
seite die panzerhaubitzen 2000 treffen
jetzt ein und auf der anderen seite
fühlt man auch in diesem land dass sich
viele jetzt nur noch um ihre
gasrechnungen kümmern dass viele den
eindruck haben dass muss jetzt zu ende
gehen es muss irgend ein kompromiss
gefunden werden wir wollen dass alle
nicht mehr so da auch stimmen aus
deutschland was sagen sie denen
schauen sie die bilder
um letzter tag
mit russischen reagierten am
einkaufscenter
im körper dorst und
wir sind bilder zum beispiel vor allem
mädchen ein siebenjähriges mädchen die
masche ist ermordet worden
von dieser kette und man fragt dann
welche preis zu bezahlen
ein erhöhter preis
zum gast an diesem sinne und dass man
sich wirklich von diesem
meiner palais was lg betrifft sich loest
und freien scheiben kann und nicht
irgendwie eine diktatur übersicht hat
dazu dann muss man schweigen das
anklicken der ukraine nachbar land
herrscht und da werden die auch die
kinder
zivilisten
einkaufscenter infrastruktur zerstört
oder man zahlt dann einen höheren preis
für gas oder man findet sogar eine
alternative für diesen preis eine
alternative dass man sich jetzt von von
diesem mann ab ali der energielieferung
und ich glaube dass in die weltmaschine
gerade im wichtige sagen dass man
gesteht dass seine bally auch tödlich
sein kann und so eine reaktion entsteht
dann auf ein bald von sohnemann überlegt
man meiner palais man muss sich lösen
wenn man muss ich ihnen vor einmal
bewegen und nicht nur abhängig machen
von einer struktur oder oder einem markt
in dem sinne wie
klitschko wie geht es für sie jetzt
weiter sie sind momentan in madrid
werden sie danach direkt zurück in die
ukraine kern und wie sieht es momentan
ihre arbeit vor ort aus
es ist natürlich wahnsinnig viel zu tun
es ist es geht natürlich um die
unterstützung weil letztendlich wir sind
von der hilfe abhängig und auch
gestrigen gesprächen es gibt nicht nur
um waffenlieferungen
es ist nicht so ganz ich bin ich eine
verteidigungsministerium aber trotzdem
dass man in diesen gesprächen auch
partner findet die die sich hilfe
inklusive inklusive selbstverteidigung
waffen euro meint erich hilfe jeder
andere art dass man wirklich in diese
personen gesprächen diese akkus punkte
findet und letztlich für die ukraine das
liefert und es ist enorm wichtig um
genau so wird es weiter gemacht auf
meine seite umgestoßen oder sein kann
es ist auch ganz wichtig gewesen dass
das die ukraine auch teil dieser
konferenz gewesen nicht nur von
gesprächen und von medien wie man das
oft bekommt weil medien sind auch nicht
in das darf man nicht vergessen und das
kann auch zu einer waffe sein sowie dass
russland mit
mit propaganda dass das macht in jedem
land laufen
fernseher oder radio
oder zeitungen die juli berichten dass
die ukraine zu stellen ihr eigenes war
so wie das vor kurzem gesagt wurden von
der seite das erzähle nicht auf bank
aufs tempo das ist alles propaganda
genauso wie butscher propaganda von der
ukraine und in die freie welt sowie
busche gäste mail an die opel haben wir
auch deswegen eine der wichtigsten
waffen auch in die welt zu berichten und
zeigen dass die ukraine leidet
wahnsinnig und wir brauchen diese
unterstützung wir verteidigen auch ohne
werte wie sie mit einem boot und es ist
ganz wichtig diese aggression die von
russischer seite gekommen ist zu stoppen
seit zweiten weltkrieg gab es so eine
lösung so ein krieg in europa nicht und
deswegen ist es enorm wichtig an
verschiedenen fronten zu geben sie haben
auch mit olaf scholz gesprochen welche
wichtige nachricht haben sie hier den
kanzler mit auf den weg gegeben was
erwarten sie
ich glaube dass die politik von schulz
hat sich wahnsinnig stark verändert
wie das amt während des krieges war als
ich noch zu besuch war
im märz anton bis märz vom märz und es
ist unglaublich zu spüren dass die welt
wird immer klarer sein wer diese krieg
angefangen hat was diese krieg heißt wie
schlecht das für die ganze welt sein
wird man darf nicht vergessen dass eine
halbe milliarde menschen leiden wird für
uns weil wir über das schwarze meer will
die ukraine nicht unsere unsere getreide
liefern können und so weit also wie sind
in einem ökosystem die welt ist zwar
größer bis viel kleiner geworden und wir
sind alle miteinander verbunden
irgendwie alle voneinander abhängige
sind und dann wenn sowas passiert wie
ein krieg es muss man gemeinsam agiert
um gestoppt werden und dass er diese
internationale recht darf man nicht
brechen dafür haben wir die zwei
weltkriegen in dons und das darf nicht
passieren dass du so was schon wieder
passiert besten dank für das gespräch
werde mir klitschko-lager film sagen und
dankte deutschland für die unterstützung
er macht enorm viel für uns für die
ukraine für die welt vielen vielen dank
ich habe noch nie ich habe noch nie
gespürt wir gesehen dass vor allem auch
um deutschland über 850 millionen
privatspenden von verschiedenen
unternehmen oder privatpersonen sind
gelaufen es ist umso als medium
geschlossen könne danke durch vielen
dank für ihre aufenthalte riechen dank
danke vladimir klitschko für dieses
gespräch danke
versprechen wir weiter über das thema
mit unserem militär experten und politik
schaftler maximilian der halle an der
london school of economics schön dass
sie da sind sie haben auch das gespräch
gerade mit wladimir klitschko verfolgen
können also die ukraine sie braucht
warfen sie braucht auch schwere waffen
warum bekommen wir aus deutschland vor
allem bundeskanzler olaf scholz das
nicht es ist kaum nachzuvollziehen
wir könnten wenn wir wollten auf einen
schlag 100 marder und leopard 2 weil ein
sinken wir könnten diese waffen die in
den depots stehen jetzt und hier
losschicken
wir tun das nicht aus gründen die sich
daraus ergeben dass wir keine strategie
entwickelt haben für diesen krieg wir
wissen nicht was dieser krieg
tatsächlich mit uns zu tun hat wir
wissen nicht dass nur die niederlage
putins tatsächlich ein freies
zukünftiges europa ermöglichen wird das
wollen wir nicht wahrhaben und deshalb
zögern wir vergeben einiges aber häufig
zu wenig die letzten drei artillerie
geschützte die jetzt geliefert werden
jetzt zugesagt wurden das ist einfach zu
wenig die botschaft den man damit sein
könnte wenn man wollte ja ja die würde
ganz anders lauten würde man diese
leoparden und die die maler schicken
dafür hätte aber auch die
bundesregierung g7 nutzen müssen um die
ja auch hier zögerlichen amerikaner
überzeugen zu können nicht dafür raum
gewesen man hat es nicht getan man will
es nicht tun so bleiben die fragen offen
und die ukraine steht dorthin
johannes und anderswo und kämpft unseren
krieg wismar wollen haben wir heute
nicht und man fragt sich auch was wird
irgendwann was wird irgendwann danach
passieren wie wird ja die weltordnung
aussehen wie wird es gehen mit oder ohne
putin auch der bundeskanzler hat sich ja
bei g7 dazu geäußert hat ganz klar
gesagt das wird nichts mehr sein wie
davor wie kann es aussehen ja davor
steht dieser krieg und der muss geführt
werden und der muss aus meiner sicht
gewonnen werden sonst werden wir ein
hatte mir putin haben sollte er den
krieg gewinnen oder aber einen
waffenstillstand erzwingen wenn ich mir
ganz sicher bin dass viele teile
westlicher gesellschaften sofort die
initiative
neben würden sagen ja seht doch er will
doch frieden et cetera und
man vergisst dabei die eigene geschichte
nicht wir deutschen müssen eigentlich
besser wissen als jeder andere dass
diktatoren sich nicht satt uhr ihren
also befriedigen lassen nicht hitler den
krieg lechleiter das hört sich aufgehört
nach einigen gewinnen sondern musste
daran gestoppt werden und so ist es mit
putin auch zumindest in dieser hinsicht
ist der vergleich glaube ich richtig er
wird nicht aufhören bisher daran
gehindert wird und zwar mit
militärischer gewalt da gibt es noch
andere mitte auf denen wir auf den
finanzen wirtschaftssektoren die weit
besser genutzt werden müssen wir sehen
jetzt dass die sanktionen gegen das öl
das die nicht ziehen er kann das öl
anderswo verkaufen hat riesige einnahmen
hier müssen sehr breit diese
sanktionspolitik neu durchdacht werden
lücken geschlossen werden und wirklich
die wenn man so will die stahl schrauben
angezogen werden es wird ja dennoch was
getan joe biden der us amerikanische
präsident hat er jetzt erst beim
nato-gipfel auch verkündet dass er die
truppenstärken wird wie ist das zu
verstehen
das ist dass das dass das lange lange
flehen der polin die uns ob wir das
wahrhaben wollen oder nicht nicht
ausreichend trauen und deshalb aber wir
haben schon unter trump gehört damals
den polnischen wunsch dass tatsächlich
amerikanische soldaten am rennstall
daten in polen stationiert werden jetzt
soll dort ein hauptquartier für ein
amerikanisches chor installiert werden
also sehr deutliches zeichen dass
amerika vor ort massiv präsent sein will
und zwar dauerhaft
das ist alles teil von konventionellen
abschreckung das ist ein gutes zeichen
für die nato genauso wie die tatsache
dass zwei anderer staaten mitglied
geworden sind das zeigt was hinter dem
westen wenn man ihn in der nato sieht
was für eine geballte militärische und
wirtschaftliche kraft ist
dient jetzt der abschreckung das ist
ganz wichtig und trotzdem bleibe ich
dabei dieses bündnis müsste wenn man den
führungsmacht werden will wie das
kürzlich wieder aus berlin gehört haben
müsste tatsächlich sich auf die
strategie endlich ein lassen dass man
putin besiegen muss sonst wird man keine
ruhe in diesem land haben was von eben
auch kopiert wird das hört auf uns
zurückfallen wenn man ihm etwas raum
gibt dann steht ja irgendwann an der
ostgrenze der nato oder wir eins nicht
wollen dann wollen wir bestimmt das
zuletzt hatte die nukleare waffen nach
belarus jetzt geschickt oder ist dabei
das zu tun ja mit verlaub die würden an
der ostgrenze der nato stehen wollen wir
das wollen wir das nicht ich glaube
diese diese debatten die werden seit dem
24 februar nicht geführt es wird keine
strategie ausgelegt was wollen wir denn
so man hat das gefühl man gucken von tag
zu tag und hat mich wirklich eine eine
langjährige strategie ist es ist
wirklich eines tages geschäftsstrategie
wenn man so will in der nicht
langfristig wird welches europa sie
sprachen sein welches europa wollen wir
welche sicherheits ordnung wollen wir
denn und können reicht das aus was wir
dafür gegenwärtig tun ich würde sagen
nicht das ausreicht in der hinsicht
haben bleibe ich dabei ein zukünftiger
europa kann es nur ohne putin geben und
ein protein kann nicht in der ukraine
bleiben und vielleicht als letzten punkt
das heißt häufig nicht diese debatte war
militärisch kann man ihn nicht besiegen
doch man kann das in dem man ihn
überdehnt ich habs gerade gesagt wir
haben 32 staaten jetzt in der nacht mit
ihrem militär und wirtschaftliche macht
in der randstein gruppe treffen sich 40
staaten denen muss es doch gelingen
dieses recht kleine wirtschaftlichen
motor der hinter russland steht der aber
sehr geschickt agiert der sanktionen
umgehen etc den zu überdehnen und damit
ihm letztlich den rücken das rückgrat zu
brechen darum muss es doch gehen und ich
denke mir dass es dass man den ukrainer
entschuldigt ein weiterführender blick
in die zukunft und die forderung nach
einer echten straßen vielen herzlichen
dank herr der halle für ihren besuch
hier bei uns einströmen